[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my new Wonder Woman 3 video
and new Superman movie video patty
Jenkins was talking about Wonder Woman 3
recently revealing a bunch of details
for their plans so the Wonder Woman
character in the future as well as
Wonder Woman spin-off movies that
they're currently making and we found
out about new Superman movies that
Warner Brothers is planning if you're
new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos we're doing an
Amazon giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and let me know
what you want them to do with Wonder
Woman 3 in the next Superman movie so
we'll just go down the list here
starting with number 5 patty Jenkins in
the Wonder Woman cast lately have been
hyping up the Wonder Woman 1984 movie
since it's been delayed to August
currently that's still the case we're
still gonna be able to see it in August
right now in terms of the virus shutting
down movie theaters Christopher Nolan
mister Dark Knight Batman himself has a
movie coming out in June Tennant in his
adamant that that's going to be the
first big blockbuster level movie to
reopen theaters across the country maybe
around other parts of the world too just
because of all this virus stuff that's
going on in the quarantines people are
just kind of waiting to see what's gonna
happen this summer but while all these
interviews have been happening patty
Jenkins has revealed her and Warner
Brothers plans for the Wonder Woman
three movie and the Wonder Woman
spin-off movies I'll talk about the
spin-off movies in a second this is
mostly gonna be about Wonder Woman 3
right now their plan is they're
releasing Wonder Woman 1984 then they're
gonna release the spin-off movie about
the Amazons then they'll do Wonder Woman
3 number 4 but patty Jenkins said her
plan for the story of Wonder Woman 3 is
that it's meant to be a continuation of
the theme of the Wonder Woman movies so
far in that because she's so long-lived
she's seen all this world history all
these major events
Wonder Woman 3 is gonna move the
timeline forward into present day so
that when you look at all of her movies
in her eventual trilogy you have the
first movie her origin story in the
distant past and Wonder Woman 1984 with
her in the nostalgic past of the 80s
with a lot of comedy and then eventually
Wonder Woman 3 set in present-day the
way patty Jenkins talked about it she
said no more Wonder Woman solo movies
set in the past although that doesn't
include the spin-off movies the movie
that they're making based on the
Amazonian sounds like it will be set in
the past
she said part of the reason for moving
Wonder Woman 3 into present day is just
because doing movies said in the past
for her is kind of played out in setting
and present-day provides more
opportunities to build on the shared
storytelling of other DC movies a good
example is the New Gods movie that
they're getting ready to do everyone
knows about that it'd be amazing to see
them try to use someone like Grail in
Wonder Woman 3 because she's basically
evil Wonder Woman on Team Darkseid
they've been a lot of time line and
continuity changes with the way DC is
handling all of his big movies like you
have the Joker movies in that DC black
label with Joaquin Phoenix that
technically aren't connected to the
other DC movies but then you have some
DC movies that are connected like birds
of prey is connected to Suicide Squad is
connected to the Justice League movies
Aquaman Batman vs Superman the first
Wonder Woman movie even the shows and
movies are still connected to the
Justice League movies and those
characters at least the ones that are
still around not including Ben Affleck
because he's not playing Batman anymore
don't worry when we get new DC movies
like the Batman I'll explain how it fits
into the larger DC continuity plan in
speaking of Justice League - this is
actually patty Jenkins talking about
Warner Brothers general plans for the
next Justice League movie is about what
you would expect you have to go forward
so it's definitely a contemporary story
that's all I can say and so where we put
it and how that gets figured out I
haven't totally nailed down
obviously Wonder Woman had huge success
and most recently Aquaman yeah James
Wong I'm curious because it kind of
makes sense that for you or him to
direct the Justice League movie does
that interest you at all you know the
Justice League movie I find those movies
to be extremely challenging I think
they're fantastic when they're well done
but taking on all of those characters at
the same time and the timeline I sort of
hope that we don't do a Justice League
movie for a little while because I think
that each of those characters are really
great and I'm super excited to see each
of their movies and then I want to see
Aquaman 2 and I want to see flash and I
want to you know so I don't know III you
never know I would never say never but I
think that I think everybody should have
a moment to shine but talking about more
shared universe number 3 Wonder Woman 3
Justice League crossover Thor Ragnarok
style think of it that way best example
we have right now until DC does it with
their characters Minnie Justice League
movie with a big crossover team-up patty
Jenkins didn't say which character
or characters multiple they try to cameo
in Wonder Woman three but it would be
other returning Justice League actors
like Jason Momoa as Aquaman Henry Cavill
Superman there was actually some news
about a new Man of Steel movie recently
which I'll mention in a second Ezra
Miller's flash is still around a cyborg
is still around Ben Affleck is really
the only one they said that he's not
coming back but Robert Pattinson is
Batman movie is kind of set in the past
it's not really intended to be a prequel
to Ben Affleck's Batman movie it's
supposed to create its own little
microcosm of continuity and then maybe
later if things work out the cross
Robert Pattinson --zz Batman over with
other Justice League actors but all the
actors in all these movies have talked
about crossing over with each other
Zachary Levi said that they're trying to
get gal gadot Wonder Woman to cameo in
future Shazam movies obviously we want
to see Superman cross over into the
other movies they tried to do it with
the first Shazam movie but there were
some scheduling issues that prevented
them from actually using Henry Cavill
even though this is meant to be Henry
Cavill Superman in this post credits
scene but number two if we're talking
about Wonder Woman 3 picking the most
appropriate characters to cross over
Superman and Aquaman tonally would
probably make the most sense and even
though I love to see Superman or Henry
Cavill Superman crossover with Wonder
Woman but I actually think that Jason
Momoa as Aquaman would make for a better
pairing just in terms of how his
personality as that character and Wonder
Woman's personality work together and
Jason Momoa himself even said that is
they're getting ready for Aquaman 2 he
really wants Wonder Woman to cross over
into Aquaman 2 so we've been on the
other side of that he's working on
getting that to happen to who gorgeous
never really embraced sea or the land
I think that was beautiful
they just had this funny dynamic the
same way that Hulk and Thor's
relationship is Wonder Woman is kind of
like DC's version of Thor the way they
use her with her godly powers the
pantheon of Mythology behind her Aquaman
isn't exactly like the Hulk but he's got
that same crazy brute force energy about
him in the pairing would just make for a
more comedic duo thinking more about
Superman crossover I think he's almost
too similar in tone to Wonder Woman
which is part of the reason why it
always felt weird when DC Comics tried
to make them a thing during the new 52
comics if anybody remembers that when it
comes to that first Wonder Woman
spin-off movie though the movie about
the Amazons it sounds like that's going
to be more about Hippolyta and Robin
Wright Penn's character in the other
Amazons with a little bit of gal gadot
as Wonder Woman in it but she won't be
the main character that movie it'll be
all about the other Amazon characters if
you remember the scene at the beginning
of the first Wonder Woman movie where
they're explaining their mythology how
they were created by Zeus to help
mankind but then mankind kind of turned
on them and there was this big war
they'll probably deal more with that
backstory and the other major conflicts
with people trying to take them a skier
from them over the years remember that
epic battle scene during the Justice
League movie the big flashback with all
the combined forces of planet Earth
attacking Steppenwolf at once and the
Amazons just going crazy
picture something more like that too but
talking more about the future of
Superman number one you may have seen
the news this past week that Warner
Brothers has pivoted away from the
Supergirl movie that they were
reportedly working on in favor of doing
another straight-up
Superman Henry Cavill movie none of the
reports are calling it Man of Steel -
they're just calling it another Superman
project with Henry Cavill Superman
there aren't really any details as to
when we'd see this potential Superman
movie it would take them at least three
years because they'd have to write a
script and then take them about two
years to make it we don't know anything
about the plot or any potential villains
they use or any potential crossover
characters so feel free to theory craft
about what kind of Superman movie you'd
like to see them do with Henry Cavill
now but there are a couple of solid slam
dunks Brainiac is right at the top of
that list if you're not gonna recycle
the same old Superman vs Lex Luthor type
of story after a Batman vs Superman in
Justice League you need someone worse
than Lex Luthor there are a lot of good
picks for that Brainiac is just at the
top of that
Mountain there were even more recent DC
rebirth Superman stories were they
positioned a version of Superman's
father jor-el as an antagonist but that
was more of a trick that they pulled in
order to age up John Kent Superboy so
that they could use him as an adult in
Legion of super-heroes stories in the
future and I'm not expecting them to do
any kind of super babies in the movies
any time soon it was also an interview
with Amy Adams recently and she said
that she wasn't sure what they were
gonna do with her version of Lois Lane
but they are doing a lot of Superboy
stuff on the Superman TV show coming
later this year the next big DC animated
movie is also gonna be Superman Man of
tomorrow so while they figure out Henry
Cavill Superman movies stuff there is
some Superman stuff going on to tide you
over
but everyone let me know in the comments
what do you want them to do with Wonder
Woman 3 and what do you want them to do
with the next Superman movie there'll be
a lot more Wonder Woman 1984 trailers
and footage dropping this summer as we
get ready for the actual movie to come
out hopefully everything goes well with
that I just posted a huge Justice League
apocalypse war movie video it was a
great movie click here to watch that and
click here for my brand new Mandalorian
season 2 teaser video thank you so much
for watching everyone stays safe I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]
you